[Music]
do
any apologies anybody like me to leave
early
nope that's good um
any conflicts of interest
i would no conflicts of interest right i
would
move that we
receive the current register of interest
all those in favor either raise your
hand or say i
bye
anyone against
that's carried
right three minutes of the previous
meeting can i have somebody move that
those be accepted
thanks john seconder
thanks andrew
any discussion around those
all right i'll move that those be
accepted all those in favor hand up or i
anyone against
that's carried i don't any matters
arising from those minutes
nope we have no deputations or
presentations from the community
any adjoined business i don't believe
there is any
but we've got
a pretty short agenda so we've got the
approval of the woody and sefton
community board plan
but 20 20 22. i have may i did make some
updates
to what's in front of you but it didn't
quite make the agenda unfortunately but
that's quite normal because i was late
doing it
i added in
redevelopment of the woody beach
playground
um
developing that waikoku beach space
spatial plan
and also starting to get ready for the
woody and pegasus area strategy which
should kick off in the next financial
year
i'm also
correcting phillips spelling of your
surname in the underneath the photo
um
yeah
could you remove
the sefton domain advisory group
and the theft and township river and
drainage rate plans
direct for me because i never get a
notification of any meetings or anything
so sandra you went to a meeting of the
river and drainage
group did you
the sefton one
uh sefton ashley writing
um
so it's different in your rating
committee yeah on annual rating
committee okay
yes so it's not really it's not really
relevant to me now
hey
because there's three of them
yes
three rating area
um
meetings annual meetings they're all run
by each and second town
and ashley
and ashley whoever
yeah
john's which one's john
um it's down here is the sefton township
river and drainage ratepayer district
uh that's the seftontown that's a
separate one different one that i went
to
okay
i'd like that one removed
and the shift and the main advisory
board
um i haven't have it well i have no
contact with him whatsoever
i've noted that and i'll remove them
okay
andrew
um just two things one which i'm sure
you've picked up on but i noticed that
in the document that we're presented
with there's a number of words that run
together
so and and i presume that's just yeah
it's all the presume that'll get picked
up though just the way the
love words are laid out in the parents
in the comments okay i'll let you answer
that one um yes this is a document that
was in publishing uh publishing software
and when we converted across to word
it does that sometimes but when we go
back it should sort itself out very good
okay okay cool okay the other thing the
more significant i just and it's a
question
was that i was um
thinking about the flooding issues that
were going on
here at waikoku beach and
just
and i don't know if
they in themselves want to mention as
something we've focused on because there
has been quite some considerable work
going on to it but it's going to be a
theme that comes up
a number of times around this area going
forward the
you know sea level rise and flooding and
so forth so
should we have it as a bullet point in
some form or other in here
we also have the same issue now with
sandra sent an email out i don't know
whether how many have seen it around
flooding issues around september exactly
that's right yeah
yeah
so i can put both those in
yeah it's pretty cool
in flood flooding issues um involving
wakuku and uh sefton areas
are a concern of the boards
under infrastructure the second bullet
point
refers to working with staff to improve
drainage and
so we flood crime
including
yeah
in that one yep
yeah woody and beach is really in there
as well
um
i know some pegasus residents are going
to to raise about um
the water and some of the swales um
with the last rain with gerard and uh
he's coming to the pegasus cuppa next
month
and um they're going to raise it with
that but there was a little bit of
flooding onto the road but mainly the
swales did what they were meant to do
so
that was good anything else in there
anybody salmon wants to talk
sorry simon
sorry just in relation to two things one
uh john's
um
comments about him
his appointments
my recollection was that and i'm not
trying to give you an argument john but
you were appointed by the board to these
forums
before we removed that
can we just check police
okay that actually
um
those forums are continuing i mean one
of them is a nikken river
ecan rating district so
i doubt whether that's not um
has been curtailed at this point
i guess the question john is you're not
getting any notifications
um but kay could you just
check that out please um
uh because it is a it is a board
resolution to appoint john yeah
so before we take any action i think we
should just
check it out please if you would
i have i have checked on the
um
reserves one and they are inactive at
the moment okay okay got it all right
um
it could it could be
i'm being picky but it could be just in
brackets uh and against the name
brackets inactive at present rut can do
that
i'm happy i'm happy
i'm happy with that i'm happy with that
because it may actually pick up again
with the sefton public core
issue around that one and with the
pavilion so it may actually pick up
again at that point
thanks for entertaining my um
bureaucratic mind
we love your bureaucratic minds simon
on the flooding issue
clearly
sandra has circulated an email with
additional information but i i think
it's making
under infrastructure
making drainage and flooding issues in
the district of focus
for
um in in the and and because there are a
range of them
and and certainly and i know that's
going to get discussed sandra but
we would really want to get jared along
to the board to brief the board
and i just briefly highlight that
there's a
report going to the utilities and
roading committee on the 22nd of march
which is following up on
the thick end of 500 odd service
requests out of the
um
the may flood event
um which
brings some to the fore but not
everything and it isn't a substitute for
getting jarrod along i had a
conversation with them about that
earlier in the day but sandra i don't
want to
foreclose on any points that you would
want to make thank you
any other issues or are we happy to to
um
let me just make any minor
changes after those ones
i think it's a good document
okay would you like to move that then
john
i'll move that thank you john do i have
a seconder for that
thanks andrew
but any other discussion around that
right i'll put that to the vote that um
we approve the
the plan with
um the chairperson approving the final
version
if any further corrections are required
so all those in favor say aye raise your
hand
those against
that's carried
thanks for that
we haven't had any correspondence in my
chairperson's report is there any
questions around that
[Music]
andrea wants to ask something
thanks andrea
are you chatting it where are you
where's chat
i think you're on mood andrea
oh
no just raising
oh you're just raising your hand for the
boat thanks for that andrea
simon
simon wants something
simon um madam chio noted that you
mentioned in your report the draft
annual plan by um ecan
um i'm aware that uh there's been a bit
of discussion between the mayor and the
chairs of the community boards in
relation to
a um
common submission that doesn't preclude
boards from making their own
uh but i just wanted to get a sense of
uh because i'm i'm the pen holder for
getting a draft together
um
whether that's something the board might
want to consider
where i'm at is
there's a um
you'll recall that claire um makai and
grant edge came to the all boards
meeting um a week or so back their
comment briefing the council tomorrow
off the back of that i was going to put
together basically some slides which
try and just summarize what a position
might be in relation to the draft
circulated around the board chairs and
uh in the mirror in the first instance
before it
then gets socialized with the full
council and
and a look it may get circulated anyway
but uh whether that's uh um so
we're at the um 15th or 14th of march
um that would be
out and for review by about the 21st or
so
um and then i've got to get a report
together for an agenda
uh that closes at the back end of next
week
that goes to sorry folks that goes to
the 5th of april
council meeting
uh and i'll get us a small extension of
a couple of days on the due
date uh for receipt of that submission
so
that's my sort of trajectory in getting
that together
um so that gives you
uh the thick end of of a week to kind of
um uh express any views
uh it might not be a full week but at
least several days as to whether the
board would want to
uh be party to that uh submission
uh i'm i'm i'm fearing a bit the ashona
as to how you might want to handle that
but happy to answer any questions thank
you
yeah i have um put some questions and
ecan through tia
um but i was talking to her before and
and she's still waiting on a reply
from them even though they had promised
to have it back
on friday
last friday
so we are missing um a response to some
questions
i'll make a note to um
ensure that that's raised tomorrow
afternoon if
we haven't heard by three o'clock which
is
when the council briefing equivalent to
the all boards briefing is
yeah that would be good because claire
made that undertaking that if the
questions were put in by a certain time
the answer would answers would be backed
by the friday
so um yeah
okay i'll sort that thank you
all right um so my cheers report is
there
um so i'd like to move that that report
is received do i have a seconder for
that
thanks for
any other discussion
put that to the vote all those in favor
those against
that's carried
that we've got our matters for
information
um
now if there's anybody got any questions
around those
thanks john seconder
thanks sandra
any questions around that
all those in favor
goes against
that's carried
all right members information exchange
uh
philip we've got your report here
thank you
madam chair i'll just comment briefly on
two things
i'm the chair of creative communities
waimakariri and we're currently seeking
applications for a
round of funding
in the art area
and
it's art and the broadest sense of the
word
so if you know of any budding artists or
groups who have an activity that might
qualify
um
we've got about 86 000
and i think we're going to have trouble
getting rid of it
um and we'd like to see it spent in the
district so if there are any qualifying
things covered um
meant in our last round we normally get
about 30. we only had six apply
so we're able to carry that funding over
so we're looking forward to a good round
and i just added in the i don't know
whether you get these or not the
building consents
which shows pegasus had
147 in february
and i think that made pegasus about the
fourth highest
i suspect ravenswood is under the wood
end heading
214 consents followed by kaiapoi
and rangiora and then
i've noted pegasus
so that's about all i've got to say
happy to answer any questions
yes ravens what is included under what
end for the building consents
and we do receive those which is uh
very interesting
any questions for phillip
right john thank you for sending in
yours as well
anything you'd like to add to that
no nothing really
right andrew have you got anything you'd
like to
yeah i guess um just two things tonight
and one of them's
in your report as well shawna because
you were there we attended a meeting
with um various of the green space
council green space team
to um
as a which was a step in the uh
direction of um advancing or getting
mechanism uh getting this um
general
overview plan of the waikoku beach uh
area in place and the objective there is
to is to get a bit of a draft there's
been a number of requests from parties
of which we've seen one or two for
example the skate part and park
and the beach volleyball and if you
remember we decided that before we made
a decision
on any particular one of those requests
and the wee bits of land they might want
it would be very sensible thing to have
a overview of what's available and
green space's view on how these things
might fit together so um shona and i
were
involved in a and a continuing
discussion there and now that there's
the new team member on board and green
space um
he was um was good martin and i think is
one of his priorities is to take that
forward to discuss with the rest of the
people that have requested a bit of
space and to come up with a bit of a
plan and if i recall rightly and correct
me from wrong
but i think the next tangible step he
will bring a draft to us
as the next as a tangible step but i
don't think we set a specific date but
um come on yeah
okay so that's just one thing and the
only other thing i wanted to just very
briefly note again is that um
along the lines of the bullet point that
i um you pointed out is already there um
philip but around flooding and whatnot
there's a continuing discussion in my
neck of the woods as there are is in
other areas about the good piece of work
that council did after those big floods
mid year and the ongoing implications
and council has been active i don't know
if you recall that they
um and and jared has
said that he will come back to us with
an update on it but there was a meeting
here in waikoku beach hall that um ecan
and others were making an intended date
they were but um there's been various
actions in the part of from that meeting
which included beefing up the stock bank
and council have been out checking the
drains and and surveying and such like
so i think um
the water team is at a point they've got
some good knowledge now and i understand
that some decisions or suggestions are
very close
thank you any and anyone's got any
questions on those points
andrea given you can't talk i don't know
if you want to type anything out if
there is anything and i'll go to sandra
next
sandra have you got anything you'd like
to
tell us about you been up to sorry i was
waiting for andrea
okay um
just that email i sent to everybody this
afternoon um
uh
i should have updated you as well to um
at that meeting the residents put
forward that he can
increase um the rating area to include
um an unnamed stretch of stream that
goes into
stoney creek
that
so that it can can actually
maintain that
the rating area
uh covers
um a section above
the stream
and a section below it and the middle of
it isn't included i mean it just
indicates the hodgepodge that
is around in this area and what i would
like to um
i i think that i don't know what the
ecan process is to um
uh
to increase the rating area
uh and whether the council whether the
community board should actually be
supporting residents
who who moved and and seconded and it
was passed by the meeting bearing in
mind there was only about five or six
people there but
um uh i think that
that should be explained to the
community board in a briefing about how
how as a board
uh and potentially as a council um we
could um help out
um
the resident's
wishes
be be um
fulfilled um
by ecan
um but but
i maintain that it needs a wider brief
then um
just that i've outlined um
the issues they're not going to go away
um as i said um one household was
evacuated
um in the last and the february floods i
think that the board should actually uh
request an an update
um or a briefing from jared
and ekan
about um
what can be done in the light of climate
change and this is a flood prone area
um yet the councils can you know still
ticking off um development in there
which um you know it all doesn't hang
together well
and i think the board should be across
it
that's about it
really apart from
joining shona on the presentation from
um
tableton group about development of
pegasus which i don't know is that
shareable or is it um
whatever
at the moment i believe it's relatively
hush-hush in terms of content
um
but i might add some some information
later
yeah okay
i haven't had to put it this way i
haven't had approval from templeton
group to share i have asked
in the past
um and i'm still waiting
yeah
okay it's about me any questions um
welcome
andrew's got a question
thank you thanks very much here um
relation to your point um
sandra
in an interesting one um
just for the the general interest as
much as anything but i think it has a
wider inference um
the uh
council you can see here in waikoku
beach that council has been
um
moving quite quickly in its
interpretation of
global warming and flooding risk because
the requirements for
the building construction of new houses
has changed profoundly
so there is a house
some hundreds of meters down the street
from me that was built
two years ago that is about um i suggest
300 mills 400 mils above the ground
there are two new houses getting built
one one only like three houses along
from that one and another on the other
side of the village they are 1.4 meters
above the ground they're on piles
50 or 60 piles 1.4 meters above the
ground is where their floor level is at
so it's actually interesting and um
and it's entirely driven as i understand
it by council requirements
addressing that
risk of
flooding and global sea level rise yeah
oh indeed i mean the question is
should people be building i mean the
property that i mentioned here
um it's a relocated house that has
foundations that are um
plus
above the ground yeah um so yes the the
um the floor levels are addressed but i
mean when you still get your
your property um with 700 mils of water
um all through it in a storm seven times
since you've been there in three years
should even with the floor levels up
there
so your house might be dry but um your
solar power system and your garage and
all your outbuildings and your stock
are up to their necks and water
and that's happened several times so
what
when do you when do you arguably say
that this isn't land that should be
built on even though your house sticks
up like a sore thumb yeah
with water all around it and arguably
that exactly the same scenario could
happen in in maikoku beach you know 1.4
meters
i mean that means that it can be flooded
to that so
you're marooned in your house
up to that level
i mean is this what to my mind is this
what the council should be ticking off
no
simon
so look a couple of comments i will
endeavor to get some information uh
again available by three o'clock
tomorrow afternoon
about changes to rating districts by
ecan there will inevitably be formality
around that process
uh requiring um you know full
consultation with all
potentially affected ratepayers but at
least so
um there's some information brought to
the table about the process
in terms of some of the issues that you
raise under about
they um
straddle both what the waimakery
district council's
role and responsibilities and ability to
insist are or aren't
in the role of
environment canterbury so
there is
um despite the fact that the resource
management reform process is underway
there is a review of the regional policy
statement
underway as well and it's the regional
policy statement that enables
development in certain locations it's
the waimakariri district council that
is setting the floor levels of
development within
um
within that
remit that is enabled by the regional
policy statement clearly those things
need to line up
um
clearly it also needs to line up with
the building act and the ability for
councils
um to insist and it is still a very
um
uncoordinated and problematic area
i'm getting into a bit of detail that
will cut will come in the briefing
i think i i just want to highlight the
comments that andrew made in terms of
um
our ability as a council to insist is
still quite constrained
we are strongly advisory
um the next ratchet up is some of the
changes in the district plan
uh that will give
us a little bit more
ability to insist
but we strike at one of the um the weak
areas of
alignment between
um
national legislation
regional policy and district
planning policy and and there's plenty
of room for improvement i would readily
admit thank you
yeah thank you simon i acknowledge
everything you're saying it's just that
um given
given people who who want to
build or have bought in a flood prone or
hazard area
all the council's information is
transparently available to them
and even given that
um
uh people some people
most people actually
choose to go ahead and in fact um
now
um
you know
staff are dealing with people who who
are saying now well um i don't want to
live here anymore buy me out yeah um
you know it's it's fraught but i think
it should be in front of
the council it should be front of this
board because in fact as andrew has said
waikoku beach
beach and sefton hello
none of this this issue is not going to
magically um evaporate with the
waving of a wand and we need to actually
um
put it in front of
everybody and let's be across um have a
briefing on exactly
what's happening
and what are the potential if there are
any as you're suggesting perhaps it's
incredibly difficult
to have a solution and to actually say
hello no
is um is a thought decision but let's
have the
the information available and have a
talk about it that's where i'm coming
from absolutely thank you
why we'll say something
um
you know flooding is um a difficult
issue and
these last few events we had are very
unpredictable
um
we had uh we got a
stream that comes in off macintosh's
drain which takes the overflow from one
end
and this year the reservoir behind the
boulder dam which feeds into our lake
the water is pouring in
and then it's actually up to the same
level as a boulder game and my
brother-in-law was walking across there
and
he saw a lot of eels coming across
out of macintosh drain into our lake
so you know it's very hard to predict
you know
an event like that really
and i think it's something we're going
to have to live with
it's climate change you know
whatever we think about it as climate
changes
causing these problems
philip you wanted to say something
he's just going to say i agree with
sandra
in a regulatory sense we have the
foundation height level but it should be
quite obvious to anyone looking at that
why is it that high
um
but there seems to be a gap missing i
was concerned about purchasers who may
for instance buy a property like that
and i discovered today at zone five and
six
a person from the ministry for the
environment
spoke they are bringing out new
amendments to the official information
and meetings act whatever it's called um
that governs limbs
so they're looking to standardize limbs
throughout the whole country
and those amendments are coming in later
this year so nobody knew about it until
this person from
the ministry for the environment
mentioned that so there are things
happening but i agree with sandra and
you know whether we retreat from the
certain areas i don't believe the
district plan review provides for that
either
thank you and i'll just um just said one
thing i mean what's going to happen to
some of these people in sefton is um
their insurance policy is going to be
cancelled
because um
the person i'm particularly you know has
has
come and dropped dropped it on our
lap or my lap
and
is
[Music]
twice in six months have had their um
their solar system and their batteries
flooded out their car um completely
underwater twice in six months well
hello
um
insurance paid out on the the first time
and now
february
um it's another it's happened again
so how long do you think the insurance
company is going to indulge this
and what's going to happen when when
they say no
who's going to be yelling at the council
if they're not already yelling at the
council now so i just say we need to
have a
a really um
uh
good discussion about this and and try
and um come to some
solution or solutions
not that any of it is going to be um
easy
andrew
just a final brief comment um
an interesting discussion and i mean as
a community board
we
have limited
powers and this i think the issue we
have a role in my view to convey
information to u.s councillors and
council staff
and to take that information back
um
uh two comments lead from that which is
one does i mean the example of the place
down the road here thinking about it is
that what the house is 1.4 meters above
the ground and more um but the swale
outside doesn't work you know floods and
and the road on the way out flooded last
time around um it's exactly the scenario
you're talking about in sydne um sandra
and shona you're talking about issues
about swales and pegasus does
council um
philippines owner does council have a
clear
kind of strategy as to how to
deal with this issue because clearly
raising four wheels
is not enough there's other things going
on and you don't want to have the issues
you've got going on here at
swindle's road and whatnot it does
and i understand the council's got some
limitations on power and rights and such
like but
um but is there a
is there a plan is there a strategy a
broader one for the district and to
address these sort of issues
i guess that's going to be a subject for
the
for the briefing but um
i wouldn't say that i'm clear on on that
because the legislation as simon has
outlined hit is um
uh it gets into an area about
my understanding is um no
to say that um
it has a solution or
for it but in fact the transparency of
all the information that the council's
got and but available to anyone who
wants to build in a hazard area
is there
and then it's over to the person who is
contemplating that action i mean
you've got you're given instances of um
uh of people who are
a building in an area that will be
inundated at some point by sea level
change
and um they're building a um a
foundation of 1.4 meters
well how and how in hell are they going
to get out if if it's flooded up to 14.4
metres they are marooned and how who
knows
the circumstances
in which that will happen and what um
you know what risks other people will
have to take
uh to to rescue people and that's those
situations so i mean hello
i mean i'm saying to my mind
the council or some authorities got to
say
no
to this
um
and i i don't think you know the as far
as my understanding of the legislation
um and simon can clearly clarify that i
mean that that
move from just providing the information
and if
the the landowner is across the
information
understands
um then the council's um
council's responsibilities are
fulfilled
but um
i mean i just
the south brighton spit um comes to mind
in christchurch city
well that's clearly um a hazard area for
climate change and sea level rise and
that was tried to be put that those
warnings were try to be um included in
the
christchurch district plan and hello it
ended up in court didn't it and it was
um it was tossed out
so
fraught
but simon might like to add something
perhaps we should just um
i think the board's in agreement so
perhaps i think we should actually
follow up now and actually
put in the board's request for a
briefing yep um happy i don't want to
delay the meeting
i know i think that would be the idea
mark do you have anything to update us
on
no not really i went on the zoo meeting
um
about the chlorine and i just
read the email about i think
i don't know when that finally gets
flushed
which trip someone can tell me that but
um
they were hoping about a week and a half
can't remember like when that week and a
half is up but it must be getting close
so fingers crossed it has worked
okay
and i had to meet at gladstone park with
some head sergeants and
there's quite a lot of flooding down
there and the water didn't just didn't
go away which it normally does so it
actually has killed
um quite an area of the grass and in the
playing area
so
i'm not quite sure what the they've um
basically closed those grounds off which
may mean if um
there's further flooding that they won't
better use their number two ground for
the rugby season so um
it's a bit of a worry and there might be
some quite big remedial work there but
the ground's quite sunken and i don't
know why it's sunk
it's quite odd
um and
i also had something which i hadn't
followed i'm trying to follow up or find
out more information but some woody and
beach residents are
saying that this sewer the sewer
overflowed which um they think is
possible has possibly contaminated some
wells
um and they'd gone to the council and
asked
um about testing in the council where
you have to pay and get it tested
yourself but i don't know
that's about as much as i do i i don't
know
the details about whether sir actually
did or not but
and what we're talking about tonight it
possibly did i don't know
and we also had our first communication
monday night which was by zoom it was a
fairly quiet meeting and we didn't
really have a lot of actions out of it
so
that's it for me
thanks mark um yeah well i think we do
ask for um a briefing on drainage um
flooding and so we can add in i mean now
gladstone park is obviously something
that should be included as well
um wooden beach
good question
um
yep
i know i think i'd mention that last
meeting because it's just not long after
failing i did see a whole lot of um
couches trucks going down the window
when that was happening but
i didn't know whether that was for sure
or for water
but it's a worry if the sewer overflowed
but um
because they are all their own wells
down there
always say something
um
when i was walking down through uh
modern beach
it was
through the tracks on that
i've never seen so much water lying
around and quite deep
um
i even have i thought walk two three one
i thought was
um i had a couple of foot and i
signed up to miracles
so you know um
the the
the ovals and woody and beach
are like a wetland
they are incredible
i thought i was telling greg burns
perhaps they should make them into
wetlands
it
it looks like we dropped showed her
again oh here she's back
could you hear me
sorry apologies everyone i am having
major computer problems tonight that's
the third time i have been kicked out
so apologies
um
i'm not sure what's happening it's the
first time has ever happened
that is not good
um
so woody and beach that is
a concern though if there is a concern
around
wells
it was a company that was doing private
testing that was doing testing
but i can't think who it is
i'll try and find out for you mark
or i
have told i mean i said anyone do a snap
scene and solve it it doesn't matter
what it's for
so that's what if they have they that
may have been fed through
yeah but it was it was on the woody end
beach um or some facebook page
but it never had the lady's name and i
couldn't contact her and then i asked
someone else to find out for me who
didn't never got back to me
but that's um
yeah so i mean may it may or may not
have happened but i
i think out of all the asking for this
flooding
feedback on someone to come to our
meeting that will be very helpful
thanks mark simon um the utilities folks
keep a running list of providers of
those
testing services
so
absolutely do the snap send solve and
uh they will get contacted with details
as to who do who can provide that
service to them
hills laboratory is um one of the go-to
in christchurch it's a you need a
certified testing laboratory
yeah
and hills does a lot of council work
can't be pushing one only though sandra
no indeed
we've got andrea who's moved for a
recommendation for a briefing can we
have somebody to second
thank you andrew
and shauna looks like she's stuck again
so um all those in favor
aye
great china's frozen
yeah so
do you mind if i just continue on
um you've got the consultation project
um
[Music]
on the draft annual plan which we'll be
having a meeting on just now
um
e-scooters which is ongoing
um and migrant experiences which is
there if you're interested to have a
look at
board
funding
you've got your balances there and
all looks about right
i've got a request for funding coming to
the next meeting
but because of covert we haven't
actually you know because of all the
events being cancelled your balance is
quite high so you've only got two more
months to spend it so
please encourage people to uh put in
funding applications
um
questions understanding orders there's
nothing urgent general business nothing
um
and
china seems to have
departed for the time being
so i will close the meeting
and
yep excuse me okay um before you close
are you able to confirm whether they
bought discretionary grant balance can
be carried forward if we don't spend at
all
um they usually do allow you to carry it
forward however a lot of the boards have
got quite large balances so i don't know
if maybe the council may opt to just
bring the balances back up to what the
normal
funding balance is that will be a
decision that the council takes at a
later stage i would imagine
thank you
right so if everybody is happy i'll
close the meeting now at 6 50 and we can
move into
the workshop
thank you very much tia can you
do your
cancelling thank you
[Music]